I'm gonna prove that Whitman was at the
scene of the crime even if it kills me
[Applause]
[Music]
so while you're sitting there on your
metal toilet I'll be skydived Sky Skies
skydiving it's everything I've wanted to
eat for the last 48 hours
oh
God
it's like the firework displays
everyone needs to try both pies and I
messed that all up
I begin kaboo
we'll just add in post great you think
it's working sure I mean it seems like
you're working out the sweat
what about dress-up shorts for instance
admit that my place
what no the pious
no the flop
okay
not worth it
shut up Jake
sure uh if you could be any vacation oh
whoa I tipped him sorry
heads up eight
sorry what are they called Eight twos
eight one eight one everyone
oh hello Peralta
oh
no I know why you're so upset man I'm
the one who had to come to this
Backwater stink hole
what's up little man what's up feeling
sexy huh yeah I feel sexy yeah you look
sexy you know I do it's out for that
door
yo how much you bench seriously Gina the
D.A needs he needs he needs something
what is the DNA need the D.A needs copy
of copies of our intent
oh
I know you're making fun of me but I
would like that
[Music]
you just played your last wiener dip
oh the seat belts don't work so if we
crashed you are dead
[Music]
just kidding
I'm gonna use the key it started for
real
I did it again
not a doctor
[Laughter]
wait for it wait for it 901 Amy Santiago
is officially late for the first time
ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories uh alarm didn't go off all
three alarms all with battery backup
come on who wants to take this seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about super dark boil
but way more plausible than the Sarge's
idiotic alarm clock Theory I bet she
tucked herself into bed too tight and
got stuck maybe she fell into another
dimension where she's interesting it's 9
A.M
why is no one working Amy Santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why I like to play
I'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
Subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself I'm
too worried about it Santiago you will
tell us and you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank God damn
friends let's go as bone Bros
are you going
to go with that it was all for not
forget what you thought you knew about
the script because we're having a fun
ah hello District Attorney Terry term ah
hello district attorney kerm
[Laughter]
attorney kirm fast you are the boss
balls you said that he changed Edwards
yeah evidently
oh I think that's usable I'm just trying
to get the neo-cut
do you have any idea how long I've been
waiting for one of you old men to kiss
me
you're good Jake you're good
Charles
wait wait wait hit the button
s
come on you guys I expect more of you
here we go no fun at all
definitely something in there looks like
a peanut
you're right to cashew
player Underwood would be a good
spokesperson for a floating Casino
is there a course at Juilliard for the
giggles
[Laughter]
[Music]
I said it though you did you did you got
all the words hey
I'm gonna bind I need your help that's
what friends are for well friends might
be a bit of a stretch I mean you're a
cannibal that ate six people nine and a
half yep worse anyway here are my
options a I keep pestering her mayor to
tell me where the drugs are he realizes
I'm a snitch then he castrates me and
kicks me to death that's not great
what's option b i back off Romero never
find out where the drugs are the warden
tells everyone I'm a snitch and then
Romero castrates me and kicks me to
death both options sound a little
castrating yeah that's what I keep
bumping up against too well you know
whenever I'm back into a corner I just
do what I do best I drive across country
Forge a new identity and then take a job
as a camp counselor oh my God Caleb
you're a genius I wouldn't say genius
the camp ran a pretty extensive
background check no not that your past
is a straight up nightmare but I need to
do what I do best be a cop work the case
figure out where the drugs are on my own
and you tell the ward and the Warren
will bust Romero and Romero will think
I'm a snitch because he never told me
where they are all right this is gonna
be tough I'm really gonna have to thread
the needle oh I got really good at
threading needles back when you're
making your skin suit I know look I like
being friends with you but you have to
stop bringing that up but we're friends
what's up
uh I can do this
[Music]
thank you
yes that's a cut did we get it that was
it
great that was really good all right
let's do one more so the right read it's
pretty good this time do less Phantom
More Les Mis do you know what I mean
more more Les Mis yeah okay not a doctor
from your lawn